he is the pride of Haines City Florida
and it did not take long at all for the
rest of the National Football League to
realize that he was all business and no
joke period the first-team all-pro from
the Los Angeles chargers getting set for
his second season in the NFL during
James good to see you good to see you
I am great I'm great for meeting you
I'll be very honest with you the first
time we've met in person yeah you are a
big dude man you are I wouldn't want to
be in your life all I mean what what do
you what's the attitude when you suit up
when you put the helmet on enforcer
I want to be there for us on the field I
want to be around the ball 24/7 and I'll
make plays for my team enforcer oh yeah
so you want to make sure anybody who
understands if they're gonna catch the
ball they're gonna hear from you catch
it run it whatever you want to do with
it
yeah they will hear from Derwin James
here if it where do you get this from
where did you pick this just growing up
in a neighborhood playing playing
playing football in a row with my
friends on the sideline it just you know
the culture that we have in Florida
floor to football Florida yeah I know
Florida water Florida is that what that
is no Florida would describe for me with
the what the game in the street looked
like um I mean mailboxes there's trees
if you run to the sideline you get hit
into whatever over their cars and
there's cars on the side of the road
whatever I mean whatever's there if you
choose to run over there you get hit
over there literally nothing was that
about no I was playing this game from
four years old five year old in the
street going home bleeding mom mom mad
at me but you know it made me tough as a
kid I bet it did anybody that you played
with in the street are they in the NFL
now oh okay
you've got some serious family members
as well right in played football oh yeah
Edgerrin is it because Edgerrin James is
a cousin yes what so what's your memory
of watching him play so he's a beast huh
he ran the ball at Miami really well got
to the NFL won Super Bowl I mean he's a
good player
okay did you spend much time with him as
a kid but not as more not as much you
know so how so that's why you wound up
at Florida State oh yeah I'm a Florida
stager how'd you get
Florida State I mean my mom is crazy my
mom was a Gators man my dad was a
Hurricanes fan so I just picked in the
middle like keep everybody happy if you
keep everybody happy but you're in a
Florida State
but I was always a Florida State thing
and why is that it was just when I was a
kid or some up the horse and when they
planted the spear in the ground I don't
know when I was a child it kind of got
my attention
and then is watching players like war
done Peter Ward and those guys and I was
like now I want to go to it and he got
The Godfather in prime no plan time for
sure now once you first meet the young I
met Deon when I was in high school
because you know beyond does all the
unarmored camps and does different camps
so I met him got to work with him at
all-american game and worked worked a
couple camps for him back in his home
time and take kidding what you do oh he
had a camp in Texas
I guess the prime prime prime camp
uh-huh and I went out there and worked
it for him one year when I was in
college so it was a good okay and then
obviously when you went to Florida State
I'm sure you you you were in touch with
oh yeah sure - and then I always loved
watching him when he goes on the field
at the combine oh yeah also when
everybody's out there working out and he
was there with the microphone for the
NFL oh yeah for sure
and everybody knows where he is and who
he is and all that stuff who do you
model your game after uh you know me I
just tried to be the best me but I I
take stuff from everybody's game you
know like I said I'm not the same size
as everybody in the same ability like
let ability but I try to you know I
watch every growing up Ostrow Paulo Malo
how he played the game Sean Taylor um a
lot of guys I just try to take something
out of their game and try to add in my
game well the thing about Paulo Malo is
so many times he wasn't in the place
where he's supposed to be I know and
that's what makes it know right where
his instincts will wake over and his
instincts are gonna take him to Canton
Ohio that reads about to go in and he
always would always thinks take it to
the house those boys thought oh yeah you
know back in the day yeah so Derwin
James and the Los Angeles chargers here
on the Rich Eisen show I want to go over
a couple numbers here obviously there's
more than just numbers it's about the
heart but what beats inside a hundred
your first charges rookie with a hundred
or more tackles in a season that had
never happened
period you did it move so what's with
the seventy seven rating of tackling
I don't know I don't know Matt and Matt
and I don't know we got to get that figs
I mean when I seen that I was kind of
disappointing I saw that yeah I was
disappointed in Matt and what I'm a
plant matter in a long time I was
disappointing and then you you you
finished with an 87 last year right yeah
you III see you the first charges rookie
to be named a starter in the Pro Bowl
since lights out did it in 2005 your
first-team all-pro on top of that and
your rating went down by one I guess
they want to see it again
it was first year so uh you know they
probably want to see it again cut pisses
you off it kind of pisses me off why
what does it matter it's a video game
right I mean I play it a lot you know
everybody plays matter what is this it
about a respect you know okay so are you
gonna you know wear that on your
shoulder during the season I got a chip
on my shoulder I know you already do
already
yeah I play with a a I don't with a chip
on my shoulder anyway did the now the
Chargers lined you up at linebacker last
year as well correct yeah everywhere all
over you like that I love it I love
everything about Bo mane anyw anywhere
on the field you know I play you know
I'm like I said just like making plays
okay Derwin James here on the Rich Eisen
show if we hooked you up with Matt and
what would you tell them right now fixed
it on my game no I saw what do you mean
you already fixed I mean if you play on
my system my tackling is higher than the
77 what you put yourself I'll put it at
a ninety nine so you played me on my
system like mom already at ninety nine
on my system um is there any rating on
your system where you're not at 99 I
mean I mean I just changed the tackling
cuz I you know oh just okay the tackling
in the strength I put the Scranton 99 to
do okay what would you give my madden
rating me you for my speed during its
own I've been watching a lot of videos
okay no I don't I'm aware of that yep
yep not now look you know I know you're
disgusted oh man yes you have noticed
that you bring in faster
I've probably got to give you I give you
a seventy man a 70 yeah you know what
you're just being nice though right I'll
give you a 70 a 70 now if I got that
rating I would take to my phone and I'd
bark at it too
I'd send that out on Twitter also what
would you say I don't know 99 no no
[Laughter]
don't laugh too hard
but this is for reference right there
okay
Brady's speed is 60 um I don't know
tbh 12 is you know on the TB 12 system
on the re 50 system right now you know
but yeah I'm you know I'm working on my
my my getting out this year though I got
to be honest with you my I hurt my groin
during my first run and I ran it three
times I think it might be the sumo but
you might get into fours you get out of
whoo don't you think you know but I
don't would that's my uniform oh yeah I
know I do know what you're saying yeah I
mean snoop told me one time don't wear
the long time oh you know you camber Eve
not really it's funny D on one time ran
it backwards for the first 20 miles 20
20 yards and went stride for stride with
me backwards oh yeah Phillip Rivers is I
think his ratings is 65 his speed rate
is 35 so you're giving me a better
rating than Phillip Owen I gotta tell
you that didn't I thought it was being
generous what's it like being a teammate
of Phillip Rivers oh it's great man he's
a great guy in the locker room great guy
to be around
I mean he's a team leader you know he's
just a competitor every day in practice
he's pushing everybody receivers even
DB's he pushing everybody to be great
you know I got a lot of respect for me
is it true if he has a 10th child the
child's name will be Darwin is that a
true story it was got a lot of children
but have you have you babysat Oh is
there anybody you don't do that you
don't babysit I belacan you know I
babysit my own self you know you seem to
be doing a good job you know it's gonna
be good you seem to be ready for the
season
oh yeah I'm ready who is the best safety
in the National Football League come on
huh I love this comp come on man you
really believe that don't only turn on
the tape turn on the tape I mean Dinah's
got aa
take what's your goal for this year just
coming out and being consistent you know
helping this team get to a championship
and on whatever whatever I had to do to
do that you know I'm willing to do it I
know I'm gonna make plays I mean I was
born to play football so you know I make
you really think that you're born you're
put on this planet I play football for
sure well then thank goodness you found
it oh yeah and then you're able to do I
mean talk about a blessing that you get
to do this for a living major blessing
Southern California too
ain't no better place I was about to say
look it's funny every time I talk to
Dionne about how he could have chosen
where to play football he goes notice I
did not go anywhere where it was cold oh
no for sure man I have never played in
cold water never besides we were plated
laying up for the playoffs those yeah
one of the quote doesn't my Cody's name
ever after well I mean it might have
been your coldest day ever
yeah I never had played a note like that
and what was that like it was brutal
it was you couldn't get out of your head
huh you know and hearing here in Los
Angeles what do you want Los Angeles
fans to know about the Chargers oh man
you know what would underdogs here
you know we're overshadowed by you know
of course the Rams and everybody always
under looks us but I feel I want to come
up and we got a lot to prove in them and
we got a great team okay yeah you're
coming you mean that stadiums just up
the road oh it's gonna be your future
home oh yeah for sure
can't wait are you gonna bring you're
gonna plant that flag I need yeah I
think big lightning bolt I am very
excited for you before I let you go pass
interference is reviewable this year I
asked I'm asking anybody who's on that
defensive side of the ball certainly
when people are coming right at you you
have no idea what route they're gonna
run I mean you can do your film study
all you can but you are somewhat
attitude disadvantage when somebody's
running around in your direction hmm are
you concerned about instant replay
whatsoever I don't really care I mean I
don't have to touch a receiver I feel
like I can cover so arriving late
arriving just on time maybe I mean that
sort of thing you're not concerned about
that I'm just gonna play football and
whatever decision they feel they make I
mean I'm gonna live with it you know
next play what do you do when you're not
on a football field play matter so you
really all about the game here yeah
that's why I was disappointed you are I
mean what gives
I mean from 87 89 go to
some more numbers but I don't want to
upset you anymore I know I was okay so I
mean you you want I'll give you one last
stay here I mean you want to say
something to the Maddon people here on
the Rich Eisen show before I gotta come
check a game out of some come to a
practice or some get some of those
numbers fit come on down to Southern
California just come and watch and you
know come and watch Darren James at
Derwin James on Twitter and on Instagram
great to see you great to meet you thank
you got any time
I'm gonna call you during the season oh
yeah when you go ball out you hit
somebody or whatever and then you work
on your golf game I'll work on my
running and then move on the other day
was a bad day man I think I think what
do you think that was for me at the
compound you think that was a walk and
I'm not you me I mean if you do it more
than once it can't keep me in a bad you
know okay well I mean I do it once a
year I mean if you wanna kick Derman if
you want to talk top-end speed once a
year for me yeah Derwin james on twitter
and on instagram check out your Los
Angeles chargers when you come here to
Southern California charges training
camp is open back with more in a moment
for more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for free
on BR live or download the Rich Eisen
show app